ein zusammenhang heute gibt es eine
challenge denn coca cola mich
herausgefordert ein drei gänge menü zu
zaubern unter dem motto zero das
bedeutet entweder gibt es zero strom zb
darf ich meinen strom nicht verwenden
oder zero zeit dann habe ich einfach
keine zeit für das jeweilige gericht und
ich bin jetzt einfach mal gespannt was
bei rumkommt denn hier sind die lose und
ich habe mir gedacht ziehen darf das
niemand geringeres als hamza
nicht mogeln kann also ich muss jetzt
aber theorie und haust du das machen
jetzt gehst du die vorspeise sowas ist
jetzt das handicap quasi das sich
bekomme angespannte budget simon budget
das heißt es muss so sein dass einfach
kein gekostet oder kaum geld kostet also
immer ich kann
also etwas ist so vergünstigte schritten
zum beispiel griechischen das wäre ja
gelacht und kriege ich hin ok just zum
test ist wieder kommt auch so ihr großes
jetzt ich mach das jetzt erklärte sich
so für die sieger budget challenge habe
ich mir gedacht was macht man denn so
als vorspeise ich bin immer gerne mit
brot in irgendwelche tipps rein und was
passt besser als humus also diese
kichererbsen passte die lief über alles
und ich mag dabei voll ein bisschen
nimmt gleichmann mixa und mich dann
einfach die ganzen zutaten ich hatte
noch eine eine konserve also eine dose
mit kichererbsen das gute ist bei
solchen konzerten produkten sind die
kichererbsen schon war ich das heißt
wenn ihr drückt dann sind wir total
weich und dann muss man nämlich extra am
tag vorher ein weichspüler kurz unter
wasser
[Musik]
und dann kommen die hier direkt in den
mixer und damit sie sich besser mixen
lassen gebe ich da gleich noch so ein
bisschen wasser mit dazu und außerdem
auch schon direkten spritzer
zitronensaft und olivenöl das sind
flüssige zutaten die nicht nur geschmack
geben sondern auch für die konsistenz
zuständig sind
[Musik]
wo kichererbsen sind da ist technisch
weit wenn das gehört zusammen wie salz
und pfeffer so und da kommt jetzt
einfach noch ein bisschen was von
italienischen euch nicht wundern
weiterhin ist es so dass die ölschicht
von sechs haben sich oben absetzt und
dann einfach kräftig rühren und dann ist
wieder alles ins moos da gehe ich gleich
übrigens nach knoblauch mit rein gesagt
und was niemals lehnen darf es
kreuzkümmel denn das wirkt einem
blähbauch entgegen weil kichererbsen
können aufnehmen werden und die
kreuzkümmel nehmt dann passiert das
nicht
[Musik]
so den humus habe ich jetzt schön
angerichtet da muss in meinen augen
olivenöl nochmal on top so ein bisschen
paprikapulver eigentlich nur für die
optik geschmacklich tut sich jetzt nicht
und was ich finde für die optik muss
immer so ein bisschen was grün ist da
habe ich jetzt einfach petersilie haben
wenn ihr das gerade zufällig da hab dann
schreit es einfach noch mal drüber und
was ich auch finde ist dass man muss
immer mit irgendwie einem fladenbrot
oder baguette brot irgendwas da man
wollte was zum trinken das ist ja auch
klar und ich hatte jetzt noch so sag mal
altes bargeld
das reicht nicht wer will nochmal so ein
altes bargeld und viele denken wenn tat
ist das kann ich damit noch anfangen ich
mache so dass ich einfach mit ein
bisschen olivenöl das ganze von beiden
seiten an rost sondern haben wir noch
knackiges baguette dazu und dann kann
der hansa kommen zum testen
[Musik]
haben sie für diesen test ist brauchen
wir kein besteck
hallo es wäre ihr zu merken mit der hand
gegessen gerichts bargeld lager also ich
muss jetzt kein messer nehmen und drauf
machen
kann da ist übrigens commerce experte
seine schwiegermutter macht das in
bester form aus in ganz deutschland bis
jetzt dachte ich das ist schlechter
warte
stift aber es ist besser als stütze dass
die dosen dieser ersten gewinnen das ist
okay das nicht so frisch angelegten ja
aber es schmeckt schon ziemlich frisch
schmeckt frisch und hause kommt apropos
geschmack seid ihr auch team so dass die
portfolio von coke wird durch
kalorienfreien süßungsmitteln erzeugt
von daher schmecke die produkte auch
angenehm süß obwohl sie weniger kalorien
enthalten oder bzw nahezu kalorien frei
sind
der hauptgang
aufgeregt bin ich so ein bisschen die
spannung steigen
zero kompliziert sieger komplett
passiert ist hört sich auch sehr
kompliziert aber was heißt das also ich
denke da so anders dass wo man jetzt
irgendwie nicht gerade fünf stunden
verbrauch so das ist dann nicht
kompliziert ist also ein einfaches gerät
und kompliziert was auch ein anfänger
jetzt der neuen küche ist ganz schnell
einfach nach
dem ersten moment so die sportgerichte
aber die frage ist macht es dir mit
nudeln die ich immer mache oder nämlich
kartoffeln oder reis
ok also
ich hab mir jetzt doch für einen spot
gericht mit reis entschieden weil ich
einfach doch dass das was anderes als
immer nur nudeln und es habe ich den
letzten jahr gemacht ganz spontan hatte
da richtig lust drauf und es hat
wunderbar funktioniert wir nehmen sogar
hähnchen betreiben aber zuallererst
einmal eine zwiebel fein würfeln
der pc schon öl in einem topf bei
landgerichten brauchen wir auch mal
einen pot also einen topf oder eine
pfanne sondern gebe ich jetzt erstmal
die zivil rein knoblauch darf nicht
fehlen und auch schon das hähnchen das
habe ich in der mundgerechte stücke
geschnitten dass hier kommt auch direkt
mit dazu wichtig ist dass er das jetzt
nicht irgendwie trocken anbraten also
eineinhalb bis zwei minuten reichen
vollkommen danach gibt auch schon da
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich schon mal salz und
pfeffer mit dazu getan und als nächstes
kommen paprika und tomaten nation ich
überlegt habe vielleicht noch ersten
dazu nehmen sollte ich erst gleich im
schrank für den kommen hier auf jeden
fall noch mit dazu und die schneide ich
jetzt auch nur sehr sehr groß und die
tomaten geben nochmal schön saft ab das
ganze wird dann quasi mit wasser
abgelöscht und ich gebe mir gesagt kreis
mit dazu und da ist es noch persönliche
präferenz mögt ihr den klebrig weil reis
beinhaltet ja auch stärke ich nehme was
martin lang korn und möchte den klebrig
dann erwacht ihn nicht wenn ihr den so
schön körnig und fein mögt dann warst es
gerne aus dann merkt er dass das wasser
ist trüb rauskommt und wenn ihr dann
immer weiter was dann ist es nicht mehr
ganz so tritt also ganz klar wir jetzt
nicht aber es ist auf jeden fall viel
klarer als vorher
[Musik]
da kam jetzt noch gewürze rhein ganz
easy paprikapulver ein bisschen chili
dann habe ich noch gemüsebrühe dazu
getan und das ganze einfach mit wasser
bedeckt jetzt warte ich darauf dass es
schön hoch kocht und sobald es wirklich
einmal globart könnte er mit der stufe
runter auf die zwei von neun oder
eventuell sogar drei von neun und dann
kommt einfach der deckel drüber und dann
braucht das gericht nur noch 20 minuten
ich bin so ein bisschen aufgeregt
vorhabens bewertung muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen wir sind so reich und
zimmer einzeln kochen
lecker lecker ich kann mir jetzt auf
jeden fall eine 20 minuten pause und ich
serviere gleich zum hauptgang wenn das
gegart ist justine ist auch ohne zucker
in der sorte schwarzer tee himbeer minze
schmeckt gut und passt auch super gut
hier gleich zum hauptgang und ihr kennt
wahrscheinlich die ganzen klassiker als
zero produkte zb
panthers breit oder mezzo mix und es
gibt eben auch fluss tejo variante und
das könnt ihr gerne mal ausruhen
schmeckt echt gut
[Musik]
der hauptgang habe ich diesmal
sportgericht mit reisecars schildes
kommune war auf dich mal was war das war
jetzt das motto unter das motto ist
immer kompliziert es ist alles in einen
topf in standen sie doch passiert aus
das heißt sie beleidigend an weil ich
meine dass ich mir das
nochmal genauer auf die rente tiere ja
ich will dich raus kommt mir der griffel
vorne würze herrensohr eises klar und
alles super
ich hab
mich drüber ich habe ja schon probiert
beim selen bei den juti shots und dazu
gibt's heute ohne zucker
und wisst ihr was ich feiere jedes
dritte produkt aus dem hause coca cola
ist jetzt schon kalorienfrei oder
kalorienreduziert so haben wir euch
bezwangen genießt noch in aller ruhe
einmal und dann nehmen wir wahr zu
letzten challenge
geschüttelt nicht gerührt wie gut kennen
sie so ok das
ok dann können sie ja fast um hass athen
frei ist also das ist ja also beide
erhalts nicht gut aber unsere kamera
frau sarah ist
die neue internet ist wirklich okay dann
macht aber ja ich mache da fällt mir
schon direkt aus einem laster
überraschend auf knopfdruck
3ds erst mal bin ich
überhaupt so schmeckt wie gesagt so dass
er ist für mich eine quasi heim vorteil
dass das team sie das kriege ich hin
fallen auch immer ganz gut ersetzen kann
durch zum beispiel gemeinden müssen ich
hab mir grad haselnüsse man kann auch
mandel nehmen speisestärke nämlich mit
dazu also leider trio mit wäre gelacht
so und jetzt bin ich jetzt aber erste
wahl und schlagt die auf in einer
schüssel das ist auch es kommt man
könnte auch sagen es ist nicht nur sie
sondern auch noch zusätzlich sehr
kompliziert weil ich nicht mal eine
maschine dafür brauche ich werde das
beste alles vom schneebesen machen das
geht so schnell dass ich den ofen auch
schon vorgeheizt habe auf 180 grad ober
unterhitze das einzige was ich hier
vorbereiten muss dass ich glaube dass
minister dazu das einzige was ich ein
bisschen vorbereiten musste ist ich habe
vor mich kuvertüre gehackt und bei
geringer wattzahl dass ich habe 360 watt
genommen für ungefähr eine minute bis
maximal anderthalb minuten in der
mikrowelle verlassen also geschmolzen
besser gesagt und da habe ich einfach
zehn minuten abkühlen lassen hat den
einfachen grund ein bisschen er hat den
einfachen grund dass wir dann gleich
kein ruhiger haben dadurch dass die
temperatur der schokolade zu heiß ist
das gebe ich jetzt noch mit dazu dann
wie gesagt speisestärke dazu ein
bisschen backpulver und wenn es der teig
schon fertig
[Musik]
es fehlt noch was ein eine prise salz
denn die hebt ja nochmal den süßen
geschmack
noch mal schnell unterjubeln kurz
verrühren und jetzt einfach ein film ein
tortenring hatten durchmesser von 16
zentimetern das wird ein schönes für
eines küchlein und ich würde sagen die
schlag dann gleich während das packt das
braucht 20 minuten bis maximal 22 und
dann mache ich mir zwischenzeit schon
mal frische sahne fertig das heißt
einfach aufschlagen ein bisschen vanille
extrakt und dann wird das zusammen mit
frischen früchten serviert
[Musik]
so haben sie das ist ein stück
bayerische sand drauf frische früchte da
fehlt mir wie sie
zu dem air design da oben
ich wusste gesetzt was ist da drin ist
die challenge rasierer mail und ich habe
statt mail einfach speisestärke und
haselnüsse genommen diese gemeinde
handeln müsste es ist immer noch prozent
es ist jetzt nur noch dorthin frei sein
lecker lecker und drei minuten arbeit
für den teig wer könnte ein bisschen zu
kalt aber heute sind die asyl genau
heute sind wir sehen aber ich muss sagen
also ich hab ja auch probleme vom teig
gemacht es ist halt weg ist es so ein
erwachsener geschmack und mit der sahne
finde ich mit frischen früchten
es rundet das darf ich nicht selber
loben loser eigentlich interessiere
werden ich will heute sehr gut verhüllt
von dir der film wird soweit sein zum
simon portfolio von coca cola muss ich
sagen wir haben jetzt hier zb fanta
lemon ohne zucker dass man ohne zucker
und beinahe ohne kalorien einfach gar
keine kompromisse macht weil da man
wirklich immer den ordnern geschmack
also probiert die rezepte unbedingt mal
ausprobiert auch gerne das silo
portfolio von coca cola aus wenn ihr
mögt und ansonsten würde ich mal sagen
wir machen zum nächsten mal auf die
skizzen
[Musik]